[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend die Empörung
über das Treffen in einer Villa in
Potzdam im November ist weiterhin groß
das dort Pläne für millionenfache
Deportationen auch von deutschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte diskutiert worden
sein bestreitet der Vordenker dieser
Idee übrigens nicht AFD cochefin Alice
Weidel wollte davon heute nichts wissen
das alles sei nur eine Schmutzkampagne
und hätte mit den Inhalten der AFD
nichts zu tun warum sie sich dann aber
doch von ihrem eng vertrauten Roland
Hartwig der bei dem Treffen dabei war
trennte das bleibt ihr im
Andreas vir Reichstagsgebäude
Fraktionsebene die pressestatements der
AFD Spitze eigentlich ein Routinetermin
doch schnell wird klar Routine ist es
heute nicht so voll
heute ist was passiert ja es ist was
passiert Alis Weidel weiß genau worum es
heute gehen wird nämlich um eine vom
recherchenetzwerk Korrektiv
veröffentlichte Zusammenkunft im
November in Potzdam mit dabei auch AFD
Politiker die unter anderem mit
rechtsextremen diskutieren wie man
Menschen die nicht in ihr Weltbild
passen aus Deutschland vertreiben kann
es handelte sich
nicht um ein AFD treffen sondern um eine
private Begegnung von Persönlichkeiten
mit unterschiedlichem Hintergrund so
auch AFD Politikern und CDU Politikern
es ist
skandalös wenn linke Aktivisten mit
Stasi ähnlichen Geheimdienst und
smethoden eine private Zusammenkunft
angreifen um unbescholtene Bürger
abzuhören und
auszuspen weidels Motto
Vorwärtsverteidigung doch wenn alles so
normal so unbedeutend gewesen ist warum
hat sie sich dann von Ihrem persönlichen
Referenten Roland Hartwig getrennt der
auch bei dem pozdam Treffen dabei war
eine klare Antwort darauf bleibt Weidel
schuldig sie liegen richtig wenn Sie
annehmen dass die Vertragsauflösung im
Zusammenhang mit dem Treffen in potzam
stattgefunden hat zum Guten
gegenseitigen Einvernehmen gehört
natürlich auch dass ich mich über die
Hintergründe in der Öffentlichkeit nicht
äußern werde auch kchef kropaller ist
ordentlich auf Kravall gebürstet auf die
Frage ob er auch schon einmal bei einem
solchen Treffen dabei war gibt's eine
klare Ansage und von daher geht sie wo
ich mich privat mit wem auch immer
treffe ich sage es so deutlich einen
feuchten kehicht an
während die AFD mit sich selbst und
ihrer Darstellung beschäftigt ist von
einer Kampagne ja gar einer Verschwörung
spricht macht die Frage nach einem AFD
Verbot die Runde die Vertreter der
ampelregierung sind zurückhalten ich
befürchte dass eine große Verbotsdebatte
dieser Partei genau das Gegenteil
erreicht deswegen geht es nicht um
Parteiverbote sondern um direkte
politische Auseinandersetzung das ist
die Aufgabe der Demokraten in diesen
Tagen meiner Ansicht nach solche
juristischen Schritte ziehen ja dann
auch auch noch mehrere Jahre letztlich
der Bewertung durch die Gerichte mit
sich und auch das ist zu bedenken in der
Union ist die Sache noch nicht geklärt
während die CSU ein Verbot ablehnt will
sich der cduf nicht festlegen das ist
Sache der bundesinnenministerin
gegebenenfalls des Kabinetts des
Bundeskanzlers und bevor dazu nicht
konkrete Vorschläge auf dem Tisch liegen
werde ich öffentlich dazu keine weiteren
Stellungnahmen abgeben ich rate dringend
dazu die Debatte mit der AFD politisch
zu führen wir werden sie juristisch
meine Überzeugung nicht in einer kurzen
Zeit gewinnen können während die Politik
also mehrheitlich dagegen ist gehen
immer mehr Menschen für ein Verbot auf
die Straße so am Abend in Würzburg
worund 2000 Menschen gegen die AFD
demonstrieren gern hätte ich heute mit
Alis Weidel über all das gesprochen sie
lehnte die Einladung aber ab dann lassen
wir uns das ganze einordnen von einer
tren Beobachterin Julia Ebner ist
extremismusforscherin und Autorin einen
schönen guten Abend nach
London guten Abend aus London hallo Alis
Weide sprach heute von einer
Schmutzkampagne Medien und Politik
wollten eine Zitat legitime Debatte
abwirken wie beurteilen Sie
das die remig remigrationsdebatte
handelte im Kern von einer zutiefst
rassistischen Idee die von
extremistischen und Verfassungs und
menschenfeindlichen Organisationen
verbreitet und propagiert wird als
legitime Debatte würde ich das eher
nicht bezeichnen ehrlich gesagt bei
diesem Treffen in einer Villa in Potzdam
waren unter anderem finanzstarke
Unternehmer der mehrfach verurteilte
Gewalttäter Mario Müller aktuell
wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter eines AFD
Bundestagsabgeordneten Martin selner ein
rechtsextremer Aktivist aus Österreich
und eine ganzch normale private
Zusammenkunft sagt da Ali Weidel sehen
Sie das auch
so also normal
im Sinne von das ist nicht besonders
überraschend wenn man sich auch die
Geschichte und die Tradition von
Vernetzungen zwischen AFD und
identitärer Bewegung anschaut ja da kann
man von normal sprechen privat eher
nicht würde ich sagen wenn sich
politische Vertreter zusammensetzen an
einen Tisch und mit doch finanzstarken
Vertretern der Industrie oder
Unternehmern äh und Extremisten über
politische Pläne sprechen dann halte ich
das eher für ein politisches
strategireffen als für eine private
Zusammenkunft und auf dem Treffen sie
haben das Wort gerade schon erwähnt
wurde über Remigration gesprochen ein
Begriff der aus der migrations und
Exilforschung stammt aber halt seit
Jahren als Kampfbegriff von rechts außen
benutzt wird welchen Anstrich wollen
sich denn damit die identitären die
Nationalisten und Co damit
geben
also es die identitäre Bewegung hat eine
lange Geschichte mit dem Begriff der
Remigration es ist
natürlich Teil des Versuchs der
identitären Bewegung den des den das
Fenster des Sagbaren und das
gesellschaftlich akzeptablen weiter nach
rechts zu verschieben und da haben sie
sich immer wieder dieser Begriffe
bedient wie z.B Remigration oder auch
ethnopluralismus das sind am Ende des
Tages verhamlosende Begriffe oder
ehemismen die sie für
ja eigentlich rassistische und und
ausländerfeindliche Politik und Ideen
verwenden alles Weide benutzt diesen
Begriff auch vertreibungsfantasien wies
sie allerdings dann heute von sich das
Auftreten der AFD das ist ja insgesamt
äußerst ambivalent will ich mal sagen
auf Social Media sind sie oft deutlicher
klarer und auch krasser in ihren
Aussagen als z.B bei Fernsehinterviews
ist das eine
Taktik
das ist absolut auf ihre Taktik
zurückzuführen ich war 2017 undercover
bei der identitären Bewegung und auch
bei einem internen Strategietreffen mit
Martin seiner unter anderem dabei und
auch da haben sie sehr klar darüber
gesprochen wie sie unterschiedliche
Zielgruppen am besten erreichen können
und da geht's vor allem darum sich
anzupassen an die Sprache ihrer
Zielgruppen also in den sozialen Medien
und vor allem in den verschlüsselten
Kanälen gibt geht's da viel explizit
dazu und auch viel klar
ausländerfeindlicher als jetzt auf den
in großen Plattformen oder im
öffentlichen Diskurs wenn sie z.B von
den Medien eingeladen werden jetzt ist
es so nach diesem Treffen was wohl nicht
das erste war in
Potsdam gibt es eine gewisse
Schocksituation auch bei den
demokratischen Parteien die wollen die
AFD jetzt plötzlich inhaltlich Stellen
sagen sie und da sagen wiederum nicht
wenige das hat doch seit Jahren
überhaupt nicht funktioniert aber dann
fragt man sich was denn was
dann
es ist eine gute Frage ähm inhaltlich
hat tatsächlich in der Vergangenheit
sehr wenig funktioniert es ist auch
denke ich nur eine eine reine
Symptombekämpfung sich der Partei auf
inhaltlicher Ebene zu stellen ich denke
es wäre viel wichtiger dass sich die
Parteien die anderen Parteien anschauen
was die Ursachen sind für den starken
Aufstieg der AFD die AFD ist im Moment
am Höhepunkt ihrer Radikalität und am
Höhepunkt ihrer Popularität in ihrer
zehnjährigen Geschichte oder elfjährigen
Geschichte mittlerweile ähm es ist ist
also also wirklich notwendig sich die
Ursachen dafür anzuschauen sowohl auf
sozioökonomischer Ebene als auch auf
psychologischer und kommunikativer Ebene
sich zu fragen was können wir tun um zu
verhindern dass
zum Teil menschenfeindlich und
verfassungsfeindliche Ideen bis in die
Mitte der Gesellschaft vordringen können
was können wir tun da lautet jetzt bei
manchen die Antwort ein Verbotsverfahren
gegen die Partei oder aber auch ein
grundrech der Entzug gegen einzelne
Politiker stärkt das ihrer Meinung nach
sie haben viel erfahr kommen eigentlich
aus Österreich die Opferrolle der AFD in
der sie sich sieht oder ist es dann doch
eher ein Zeichen für die wehrhafte
Demokratie wie viele andere
rechtspopulistische Parteien auch
ist die AFD sehr gut darin sich als
Opfer zu inszenieren und ich würde
tatsächlich das das Thema des
Verbotsverfahrens mit Vorsicht angehen
also gerade ein Parteiverbot Verbot
könnte natürlich sich kon kraproduktiv
auswirken auf WählerInnen die dann diese
Opferrolle noch mehr
ja noch noch mehr auch annehmen oder die
Idee der Opferrolle
noch mehr mitnehmen also ich denke es
wäre eventuell wahrscheinlich schon
sinnvoll sich im weiteren Verlauf
anzuschauen ob man einzelnen Personen
ähm zumindest die die Ausübung von
politischen Funktionen verbieten kann
wenn sie sich wirklich verfassungswidrig
Verhalten bzw antidemokratische oder
oder menschenfeindliche Ideen gezielt
verbreiten z.B bei bei Herrn höcke kann
man sich das durchaus auch vorstellen
dass das auf rechtlicher Basis passieren
könnte sagt Julia Ebner
rechtsextremismusforscherin vielen Dank
für dieses Gespräch nach
London danke schön Ihnen auch und sie
hat gerade angesprochen Thüringens
afdchef Björn höcke übrigens anders als
Alis Weidel wiederholte er gestern
Wesentliches von selners Plänen gegen
ihn läuft aktuell eine Petition um ihm
die Grundrechte zu entziehen was es
damit auf sich hat wie das ganze
funktioniert all das auf ZDF heute und
jetzt geht es hier weiter mit anderen
Nachrichten von diesem Dienstag mit dir
gundulla in Deutschland fehlen aktuell
mehr als 900.000 Sozialwohnungen das
beklagen Sozialverbände der Mieterbund
sowie die Baugewerkschaft organisiert im
Bündnis soziales wohnen das fort hat ein
sofortiges staatliches Förderprogramm
von 50 Milliarden Euro um den Neubau von
Sozialwohnungen voranzutreiben die
Regierung hatte jährlich 100.000 davon
angekündigt dem Bündnis zufolge wurden
im vergangenen Jahr aber nur rund 30.000
gebaut Bundesjustizminister Buschmann
arbeitet an einer umfassenden Reform im
Familienrecht um neue Beziehungsmodelle
rechtlich zu stärken demnach sollen auch
leibliche Väter sowie Kinder mehr Rechte
erhalten und auch unverheiratete Paare
sollen künftig gemeinsam ein Kind
adoptieren können positiv sehen der
lespben und schwulenverband Buschmanns
Vorschläge für Homosexuelle Ehepaare die
im Falle der Elternschaft rechtlich
gleichgestellt werden
sollen die medizinische
Notfallversorgung in Deutschland soll
grundlegend reformiert werden dafür hat
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
Eckpunkte vorgestellt demnach sollen die
Kassenärztlichen Bereitschaftsdienste
besser mit dem Notruf 112 vernetzt
werden bis zu 30% der Patienten könnten
auch in Arztpraxen behandelt werden so
Lauterbach Rettungsdienste und Kliniken
sollen so entlastet werden das Gesetz
soll Anfang 2025 in Kraft treten
inmitten aller Spannungen im Nahen Osten
hat Iran Ziele im Irak und in Syrien und
nun gerade eben auch in Pakistan
angegriffen bei den Attacken
Aufstellungen der Terrorgruppe
islamischer Staat in Syrien vermuten
Beobachter Vergeltung für den
is-anschlag Anfang Januar in Iran die
mehr als 80 Menschen zum opferfielen in
Erbil im Nordirak töteten iranische
Raketen vier Zivilisten Ziel dort so der
Iran sei eine israelische
spionagezentrale gewesen der Irak zog
daraufhin seinen Botschafter aus Teheran
ab die USA übten scharfe Kritik an
Iran der frühere US-Präsident Trump hat
die erste Vorwahl um die
präsidentschaftsnominierung der
Republikaner wie erwartet und mit großem
Abstand gewonnen in Iowa wurde Zweiter
der Gouverneur von Florida des Santis
vor der ehemaligen UN-Botschafterin
Nicki haey der 77-Jährige Trump erhielt
51% der Stimmen des STIs
21% so deutlich hatte noch nie ein
republikanischer Kandidat eine Vorwahl
in Iowa
dominiert was wenn Donald Trump die
Vorwahlen und dann die
Präsidentschaftswahl im November gewinnt
was ist dann z.B mit der Unterstützung
der Ukraine diese Frage dürfte auch den
ukrainischen Präsidenten umtreiben und
so sagte selenski auf dem
Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos das was er
seit fast 2 Jahren mantraartig vor sich
herträgt wer denkt es geht nur um die
Ukraine IRT sich grundlegend heute
allerdings sagte er diesen Satz mit
Nachdruck formuliert sehr klar denn er
weiß schon auch andere Kriege und andere
Konflikte drängen auf die Weltbühne
Akteure die das Scheinwerferlicht auf
sich ziehen sitzen unter anderem in
Israel Gaza Jemen Iran Ulf Röller über
das Weltwirtschaftsforum das in einem
politisch angespannten Klima stattfindet
die Welt ist voller Krisen da wirkt der
Protest von Greenpeace in den
schweizerbergen wie ein kleines
Kunstwerk auch wenn es eine ernsthafte
Botschaft hat gegen ein grenzenloses
Wachstum auf Kosten des Klimas in Davos
finden viele Gespräche hinter den
Kulissen statt Präsident selenski macht
diplomatisches Speeddating die Ukraine
braucht mehr Waffen mehr Geld und mehr
Aufmerksamkeit denn selenski hat die
Sorge bei den vielen Krisen die
internationale Gemeinschaft die Ukraine
vergisst der Krieg wird enden und zwar
mit einem gerechten und stabilen Frieden
wir brauchen unsere Partner jetzt und
auch für den Wiederaufbau unseres Landes
und unserer Gesellschaft im ukrainerhaus
haben Sie Bilder des Grauens ausgestellt
damit niemand vergisst aber es gibt auch
ein Raum der Mut macht diese Kinder hat
Russland verschleppt und die Ukraine hat
sie wieder heimgeholt
schlafend im eigenen Bett ein Zeichen
der
Hoffnung
eukmissionspräsidentin von derlin ist
nach Davos gekommen um für die Ukraine
Unterstützung zu werben trotz wachsendem
Zweifel in
Europa wir müssen weiter den Widerstand
der Ukraine unterstützen deshalb müssen
wir die Finanzierung und die
Waffenlieferungen für die Zukunft
sichern die Krisen und die Kriege dieser
Welt haben sich bis in die Schweizer
Berge durchgefressen
60 Regierungschefs in Davos auf der
Suche nach
Lösungen Jake Sullivan könnte helfen der
nationale Sicherheitsberater der USA
aber der innenpolitische Streit lehmt
Amerika die Republikaner blockieren die
ukraineehilfe saliven mit einem
versprechen wir müssen in der Lage sein
die Waffen der Ukraine zu liefern die
sie braucht damit sie sich verteidigen
kann es muss uns gelingen
überteiliche Mehrheiten
hinzekommen Rededuell der Weltmächte
Chinas Nummer 2 Ministerpräsident lang
sucht keine Konfrontation sein Land
steht zwar eng an der Seite Russlands
aber peking will den Kontakt zum Westen
nicht abbrechen
lassen wir müssen eine bessere Zukunft
schaffen dafür müssen wir Brücken bauen
und unsere Differenzen beilegen das geht
nur
gemeinsam icher Beifall für einen Mann
der mit keinem Wort den ukrainekrieg
erwähnte und der seinen Nachbarn Taiwan
mit Krieg bedroht für NATO
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg geht es auch
um einen Kampf der
Systeme China zerstört die
Grundprinzipien der NATO Demokratie und
das Recht des
Gesetzes der erste Tag in Davos geht zu
Ende wie er begonnen hat mit der Suche
nach
Frieden ja und klar das auf dem
Weltwirtschaftsforum auch über den Jemen
gesprochen wird immerhin laufen etwa 10%
des gesamten Welthandels über das Rote
Meer doch seitdem die huthi Rebellen den
schnellsten Seeweg von Europa nach Asien
ja immer wieder angreifen kommt es zu
Störungen in den Lieferketten wird der
Welthandel beeinträchtigt die Reaktion
darauf bekannt eine Allianz rund um die
US-Amerikaner greift nun immer wieder
Stellungen der huthi an zudem versucht
sie immer wieder Raketen der bellen
abzufangen doch was ist eigentlich mit
der EU seit einem Monat diskutiert sie
welchen Beitrag sie leisten kann nun
gibt es eine erste Antwort bzw
mindestens drei Florian neuhahn zeigt
wie notwendig die
sind das vorerst jüngste Opfer hat einen
Namen zoografia ein griechischer
Frachter heute vorjemen getroffen von
Raketen der huthi Milizen so wie gestern
der us-frachter Gibraltar
Igel die Seestreitkräfte Jemens haben
eine Militäroperation durchgeführt so
der hthi Sprecher am Abend Schiffe und
Besatzung so das usmitär hätten in
beiden Fällen keine großen Schäden
anders die Route selbst das Rote Meer
Lebensader für Europas Wirtschaft mehr
und mehr Schiffe aber müssen jetzt den
teuren Umweg nehmen über
Südafrika Auftritt Europa heute in
Brüssel Sitzung der Botschafter der
Mitgliedstaaten auf dem Tisch liegt
dieses vertrauliche Papier die EU soll
Eingreifen die Frachter im Roten Meer
militärisch Schützen mit mindestens drei
Kriegsschiffen für mindestens ein Jahr
das Mandat müsste so heißt es im
Fachjargon robust
sein die Mission wird
also Seestreitkräfte zu umfassen haben
die auch in der Lage sind
Attacken von drohen von Flugkörpern abzu
wen Robert Brieger ist der oberste
Militär der Europäischen Union wenn die
Politik den Auftrag erteilt müssen er
und seine Leute den Plan umsetzen mitte
ende Februar könne man starten sagt er
während die USA längst auf ihre Art
Eingreifen reagiert die EU zu langsam
der General lässt seine Kritik nur
anklingen ja
ich denke auch dass hier eine schnellere
Entscheidungsfindung wünschenswert ist
angesichts der komplexen Prozesse und
der Notwendigkeit die Zustimmung von 27
Mitgliedstaaten
herbeizuführen vermeine ich aber doch
dass wir zeitgerecht gehandelt haben
andere werden deutlicher so wie es
ziemlich schnell auf internationaler
Ebene ging mit einer Mission am 18
Dezember so hätte ich mir gewünscht dass
die EU in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit
schon damals gesagt hätte wir sind an
Bord aus Deutschland könnte so heißt es
die Fregatte Hessen ins Rote Meer
starten als eines von drei
Kriegsschiffen der Mission wobei eh die
Frage ist ob das ausreicht wir müssen
uns vorstellen dass das das Rote Meer
und die Fläche die H zu schützen sind
wirklich riesengroß sind und da ist der
Beitrag von drei Fregatten aus der
Europäischen Union tatsächlich ein ein
Tropfen in das Rote Meer letztendlich
wird die Europäische Union daran
gemessen ob sie einen veritablen Beitrag
leisten kann zum Schutz der Schiffe
schon ein Treffer und an diesen Schutz
würde vorerst wohl keiner mehr glauben
noch also fehlt manches bei Europas
möglicher neuer Militärmission unter
anderem der
Name hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Gundula und einer wichtigen Warnung vor
Eisregen Glatteis und heftigen
Schneefällen in der Mitte und im Süden
Deutschlands davor warn der Deutsche
Wetterdienst ab der zweiten Nachthälfte
und Räter zu Autofahrten zu vermeiden
auch die Bahn rechnet mit
Beeinträchtigungen von der Eifel bis zur
Lausitz ist mit intensivem Schneefall zu
rechnen südlich des Mains mit Eisregen
Details auf ZF heute schon am Dienstag
war es in Teilen von Nord und
Ostdeutschland extrem glatt bei Kemnitz
gab es mehrere Unfälle dort kam ein
Mensch ums
Leben jetzt ist es offiziell die
Inflation in Deutschland lag im
vergangenen Jahr im Durchschnitt bei
5,9% damit ging sie zwar etwas zurück
ist aber weiterhin auf hohem Niveau
Frank betmann vieles wurde teurer wie
geht das denn weiter und womit rechnen
die Experten ja die sagen die Preise
steigen weiter wenn auch nicht mehr so
stark wie
2023 aber das wird insbesondere für
diejenigen die zur Miete wohnen ein
schwacher Trost sein erwartet wird
nämlich dass sich vor allem mieten und
Energie weiter verteuern werden und nur
weil insbesondere beim Gas der
Preisdruck in den vergangenen Monaten
etwas nachgelassen hat stiegen die
Energiepreise 2023 etwas weniger stark
als die Preise insgesamt nämlich um
5,3% Preistreiber waren vor allen die
Nahrungsmittel die zusammengenommen um
12,4% zulegten Essen wohn
Wohnnebenkosten daran kommt keiner
vorbei auch Menschen mit geringeren
Einkommen nicht die die Inflation damit
besonders hart trifft und was bedeutet
das für die Zinsentwicklung im
Euroraum ja eine weniger starke
teurerung lässt Spielraum für
Zinssenkungen die Finanzmärkte wünschen
sich lieber heute als morgen einen
solchen Schritt damit die Konjunktur
wieder in Schwung kommt aus Davos vom
Weltwirtschaftsforum dazu heute wenig
Neues von den Währungshütern ja der
nächste Schritt wird eine Zinssenkung
sein sagen Sie und ja wahrscheinlich
noch dieses Jahr doch noch einer raschen
Entscheidung hört sich das nicht
unbedingt an Frank betmann vielen
Dank in Vorbereitung einer
Weltraummission zu den marsmonden haben
die deutschen und französischen
raumfahrtbehörden Idefix auf den Weg
gebracht der Rover soll Teil einer
japanischen
marserkundungsmission sein und wird Ende
Januar in Japan erwartet der Start der
Mission ist für
2026 vorgesehen bis zur Landung auf
fobos werden dann voraussichtlich zwei
Jahre vergehen das Ziel Forschungen zur
Entstehung der
Monde und jetzt zur Handball EM in
Deutschland am Abend hatte die deutsche
Mannschaft im letzten Gruppenspiel mit
Favorit Frankreich als Gegner nach 11
Jahren ohne Sieg gegen Frankreich war
das Spiel das gerade eben zu Ende ging
sehr spannend und eine besondere
Herausforderung Deutschlands bester
Handballer um Regisseur Knor und Kapitän
Goller kommen fantastisch in die Partie
3 Minuten gespielt schon steht es :0
nichts was Frankreich aus der Ruhe
bringt nach knapp 15 Minuten trifft
Nikola Karabatic zur ersten Führung des
Olympiasiegers Andreas Wolf ist ein
starker Rückhalt aber vorn passieren zu
viele Fehler die Franzosen führen zur
Pause mit 17 Z 155 die deutschen
versuchen alles und kommen auch mit so
einem kuriosen Tor von Lucas Märtens
wieder
ran 12 Minuten vor dem Ende gehen Sie
dann sogar durch Kai Hefner wieder in
Führung aber insgesamt sind die
Franzosen routinierter drehen das Spiel
wieder in ihre Richtung am Ende heißt es
30:33 aus deutscher
Sicht aber haupthundere erreicht so
essen ausspucken das einem nicht
schmeckt Porzelan zertrümmern einfach
weil man Spaß daran hat Gästen ins
Gesicht hauen um sie zu begrüßen und
wenn man nicht bekommt was man will
einfach richtig wütend werden Kino hat
das Privileg all das zu zeigen und Emma
Stone die Gabe all das in einer
Schamlosigkeit zu tun die ihr einen
Golden Globe einbrachte der Film ist
dank ihrer schauspielerischen Lust ein
Fest und in mehrfacher Hinsicht
grenzüberschreitend der Film heißt poor
things und ist eine sarkastisch
zugespitzte frankensteineschichte Natja
nasser das ist Bella sie ist ein
Experiment der exzentrische
Wissenschaftler Godwin setzt einel
Mörderin das Gehirn ihres ungeborenen
Babys ein und erschafft seine bisher
gewagteste Kreation ein Kleinkind im
Körper einer
[Musik]
Frau B das ist Mr m hallo B ihr gehir
und ihr Körper sind noch nicht ganz im
einlang aber sie entwickeln sich mit
[Musik]
erstalichereschwiigkeit
vorem zwäe der
Gesellschaft am Leben zu sein ist
faszinierend B wieso es im Mund behalten
wenn es widerlich
ist sie ist völlig frei von
Schamgefühlen oder
Selbstzweifeln sie ist einfach die pure
Neugierde und
Abenteuerlust und sie ist begeistert von
allem was das Leben zu bieten hat ich
fand das so inspirierend und bewegend
und lustig es macht Spaß
[Musik]
funny
fun schnell wird klar die junge Frau
wächst zum unzähmbaren Freigeist heran
voller Lebenshunger jenseits aller
typischen Rollenbilder Bella will so
viel wie möglich probieren erfahren
genießen und alles maßlos mitreißend
gespielt von Emma Stone ihr Liebhaber
gespielt von Mark Ruffalo kann da nicht
mithalten wieso machen die Leute das
nicht die ganze
Zeit
[Musik]
es ist interessant zu sehen wie Männer
auf sie reagieren auf ihr immer größer
werdendes Selbstbewusstsein ihre
meinungsstarke
Natur ich finde das ist so ein
spannendes Beispiel dafür was passieren
kann wenn man als Frau so selbstbestimmt
ist das kann bei Menschen auf Widerstand
stoßen wenn du genau weißt was du willst
und dir das auch
nimmst
Po things ist ein fantasievoller und
kluger Film der das pralle Leben feiert
mit all seinen
Facetten wir müssen viele Erfahrungen
sammeln nicht nur die guten ein Film mit
spektakulären Bildern der eine eigene
surale Welt erschafft und doch mit ganz
realen Rollenbildern spielt mit einer
großartigen Emma Stone absolut
sehenswert
und eine schöne Ablenkung von der nicht
immer ganz so einfachen und
spielerischen Realität und der widmet
sich um Mitternacht in unserem heute
journal Update wieder Christopher
wermann das war's von uns machen sie es
gut wo auch immer sie sind tschüss bis
[Musik]
morgen
guten Abend uns erwartet eine brisante
Wetterlage ungefähr um Mitternacht geht
es los da zieht von Südwesten zunächst
Schnee und dann Glatteisregen auf und
dieser Glatteisregen erreicht bis morgen
früh das Saarland das südliche
reheinlandpfals und das nördliche
badenwürtemberg bis mittags sieht dieser
Glatteisregen weiter nordwärts erreicht
dann auch Hessen und Sie sehen dass auch
Schneefeld an der weißen Farbe zwischen
der Eifel und dem Thüringerwald können
10 bis 20 bis donnerst AG sogar an die
40 cm neuschneefall es bleibt gefährlich
glatt auf den Straßen weiterhin in
diesem Streifen ungefähr vom Saarland
bis ins nördliche Bayern im Süden gibt's
anhaltenden Dauerregen im Südwesten aber
bei deutlich höheren Temperaturen das
Problem ist der Boden der so eiskalt ist
heute Nacht sinken die Temperaturen auf
-1 bis -10° und an der Küste gibt sogar
noch einige Schneeschauer morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen zum meist um den
Gefrierpunkt anders im Südwesten da wird
sehr viel milder mit 11° am Nachmittag
von Eisregen und Schnee bekommen sie
zwischen der Weser und der oder morgen
nichts mit da wird sogar ganz freundlich
und es zeigt sich mal kurz die Sonne an
der Küste ziehen einige Schneeschauer
vorbei es kommt ja jetzt so milde Luft
von Südwesten heran aber schon am
Donnerstag wird aus dieser Warmfront
eine Kaltfront und so ziehen Schnee und
Glatteisregen dann langsam aber sicher
aus Deutschland raus das ist die gute
Nachricht heute denn danach wird es
deutlich ruhiger am Freitag und am
Samstag guten ab und